Let's begin a part two of rotations.
I thought I should summarize for you the
main points because you learned a whole
lot of stuff but you don't have
to carry all that in your head.
What I'm going to write down is the
essential subject you should know,
so we were going to do
rotation of rigid bodies,
which are forced to lie on the x,
y plane and they have some shape
and here are the main ideas. You should
know your first pick a point I don't,
which you want to rotate the body by
driving a little skewer through that.
That's the point of rotation.
Then here are the things we learned.
First of all,
the body has a mass m the simple thing,
you put it on a weighing machine,
that's the mass.
Then it has a moment of inertia,
which if the body were
made of for discrete set of
points would be the massive
each point m some I named the square
foot distance from the point of rotation,
but a continuous distribution
of matter like this one,
the Sam is replaced by an intake.
Yeah.
But example for a rod youth
was m l square over 12 our own,
one of the ends are on the
center of mass and 40 disk.
It was m r square over two so
everybody has a moment of inertia.
Here's the important caveat with
respect to a particular point,
there is nothing called the more medical
issue because depending on the point
these distances we'll be
okay. Then if you want that,
it did body to start doing interesting
things. You want it to move around.
It will have an angular velocity Omega,
which is the rate at which
it goes round and round.
It's the usual frequency times two Pi
because two Pi ready and set up full
circle.
Then it has an angular momentum,
which is the analog of the mass and
the analog of the velocity is just
universally denoted by the symbol l.
Yeah.
Then if you want to change
this angular momentum,
it's like asking how do you change the
ordinary moment then more of a particular
play force, so no, we apply
what's called a torque.
The torque is the reason the
angular momentum changes.
That's the analog of forces. The
reason, the usual momentum changes.
I remind you peace and V,
so it is really m DVD,
t equals m.
A so you can answer
right analogous be here.
How equals I alpha because if you take
the d by Dt of this guy that's a constant
at Alpha is at eight of tangible Omega.
Yeah.
Last thing I have to tell
you is what is the park or
the total torque on a body?
We are live. That is a force. For example,
acting in that direction.
Let me just take one force.
It is separated by a distance are auto
vector are from the point of rotation.
They find that angle data as the angle
between this point of separation,
distance of separation art and the
applied force than the Torque is f times r
five signed data.
Yeah.
If you took after be perpendicular
to this separation vector,
then scientists one your book have to
be a paddle at the separation vector at
park vanishes because it's no use,
no use applying a force in
the line joining you to the
center because you don't
produce patients that just signed data
tells you how much of the force is good
at producing rotations. If you've
got many forces and many targets,
you got to add all the torques.
That's one thing to be careful about.
For example,
you can have a body where one force is
trained to do that and he had maybe a
second force acting that way.
Trying to do the opposite.
So we keep track of the Torque by saying,
hey that it's clockwise or
counter clockwise eat fours.
You can tell intuitively by looking at it,
this guy's making it go counter clockwise.
This rotating clockwise,
counterclockwise, we'll be taken positive
clockwise, we'll be taken negative.
Similarly,
angular acceleration will be positive
if it's counterclockwise increase.
So this is somebody of what
everything we did yesterday on Monday.
You guys follow that?
So there's an analogy to f equals m a
everything has rotational counterpart,
but life is more difficult because in
the case of f equals m a m was simply
given to you here the moment of inertia.
It has to be calculated from scratch
given the mass distribution that forms the
body.
Similarly,
you may have been simply given
the forces in f equals I may,
but he had even after
I give you the forces,
you got to do some work
calculating the Torque,
but every force you've got to find how
far it is from the point of rotation.
What's the angle between the force in
the vector separating where the forces to
bear the rotation is taking place
and calculating the same day.
Okay, so that's all we did and what I
did towards the end of the class was to
calculate the moment of inertia for a
couple of objects I showed you for the
disc.
It's Mr squared over two for the Rod.
I did two calculations.
One was around this end and the want
me to finish here around the end was ml
square over three and the
moment of inertia around the
center was ml square over
and at the end of the lecture I
said notice the following fact,
that moment of Venetia through the end
and the one that did finish here through
the center of mass are
related in a very simple way.
We're just the moment of inertia with
respect to the new point is more men
definition of the Spec to the center
plus the mass of the entire Rod Times the
square of the distance Ello
were two squared separating
the access going through
the center of mass and the new access
and that's called the
parallel access theater.
And I'm going to show you
in general why it is true
battle.
Alexis theorem says that if you know the
more metal finisher who the center of
mass you are done because then the moment
of inertia through any other points
does not require you to go back and
do the whole integral. One more time.
I'll tell you the answer
once and for all the answers,
take the moment to finish of
the spectrum center of mass,
add to it in general,
the mass of the whole body times the
square of the distance between the center
of mass and your new axis. For example,
you want to rotate it around this point,
that's the distance d,
Add that MD square.
So I said,
I don't want to just give you a result.
I want to tell you where everything
comes from. So I will now prove this.
So let's start with that proof.
So this is the proof of the parallel
access theater before I do the paddle axis
theater and I'm going to
use one result in vectors.
So you might as well be reminded of
that because I use it freely and I don't
want you to get caught in that.
If a is the vector,
then the length of a square is found by
taking a.eight.is the length of eight
times the length of it,
eight times of course,
sine of the angle between a and a angle
between and zero and course signage.
Just one.
Therefore,
the way to find the length of the vectors
or take the dot product or the vector
with itself.
No other way to say this is the dot
product of a and B. You remember it's a x,
B x Plus Ayby.
So Abel itself is x squared plus y
squared, which is the length where a,
this is I want to use today is if
you take a vector, a add to it,
the vector B, and he wanted to
find the length square of a plus B,
or you take the dot product
of that with itself.
Okay?
And when you do the dot product,
you can open out the brackets as
if it does an ordinary product.
So you can do this in your head.
You will get the length of a
square from doing the a dot.
A like the big square from doing
the Bedard B. Then you'll get an a.
Dot B plus B. Dot. A and are both equal.
So you will get twice a week.
That's the result I want to use.
So here is the calculation.
So let's take some arbitrary optic
and you want to find the center,
the moment of inertia around that point.
Yeah.
This is the center of mass
and this is a part of the
body that I'm calling.
I actually you should integrate over it,
but let's do it as a song.
Mentally divide this body and
200,000 million tiny little squares,
which when tightly together found this
object because it's easier for me to work
with some than with an integral.
So this fellow has some mass m I,
it has a location which is our I,
I'm going to call it ra prime because
the prime means is the distance measured
from this new access.
I'm going to visit the symbol Ri for
the separation from the center of mass.
Big Center of mass is a privileged point.
All distances measured from it.
One kid a prime.
If you pick an arbitrary point,
I want to put a prime for that one.
Then d is a vector that tells you how
to go from your chosen access to the
center of mass.
So what does the moment of inertia I'm
paying to calculate with respect to this
point in the summer when I,
the mass of the little fellow
here am I times r I prime square,
but ra prime square you can
see is the length of Ri Plus D.
Dot. Product with all right, let's
d using this is ebay established.
Wow.
Okay. Now let's start opening out the
bracket and look at the terms you will get
first. You pick dot product of this
guy with this guy, which is Ra Square.
That's going to be, am I all
right? Square somewhere, would I?
I think you guys can recognize that as
the moment of inertia with respect to the
center of mass.
That's what you would do if I said point
in a moment of finish up this book,
the center of Mass,
you'll take the square of that distance.
So the first time I get is just the eye,
this specter center of mass.
Now I purposely want to skip the
middle term and go to the last term
in the last term. That is no some over
right because d is the fixed vector.
It doesn't have to do with
the particle. I, I get d. Dot.
D which is just the square times,
some over all the masses,
which is just the total.
And that's part of the theater
because I got the two parts,
say like I is ICM plus m d square.
The trouble is, uh, I got what
I want but I got more stuff.
I got to hope that the stuff
I don't want will go away.
Okay.
It's like putting a
washing machine or something.
And when you're done,
you find three or four parts
in the ground. You don't
know where they are there.
In that case, uh, there's no solution
to that problem. But in this problem,
there's a very nice solution.
This stuff I don't want
is going to vanish.
It's going to vanish. And let's see why.
Advantages. Let's take the cross germs.
The Cross. Jerome said like the two
eight dot. Beat terms. So here's the two,
one of the vectors a is the vector d
and it's going to be taking the dark
product with m I r I summed over I
cause there's going to
be a d. Dot. Ri twice,
but d is not dependent
on the summation index.
It's common to all the terms
of some of you pull it up.
Now you can think about what this is.
This is every mass
multiplied by his position,
so take this guy some over
I m I r I divided by the
total mass and multiplied by
the total mass,
but what is this?
Okay,
Yup.
That the center of mass but that the
center of mass in a coordinate system with
the center of mass as the origin,
so you will get zero.
You I use, this is the origin take
Mri. That's the center of mass.
It will have some
coordinators from that origin,
but these artists are all measured
from the center of mass itself.
If your computer,
the center of mass with the center of
mass is your origin of coordinates,
then it is zero.
One way to say that.
If you're sitting at the center of mass,
then all the masses are surrounding the
center of mass in such a way that the
weight of some of the positions
will be the center of mass,
but which will be then zero if
that you already have coordinates.
That's the reason this advantage,
this is a very useful result.
The center of mass coordinate in a
coordinate system at the center of mass at
the audit as the origin will therefore
be zero and that's where this drug
manages.
Then I get the result I mentioned to you,
I use ice center of mass
plus and these square
and the rod was a special case of this,
but I put the equals l over to do
that exam. What does generally true?
Okay? One useful. One place where you may
find the result. Useful is the following.
Let's think about the moment of
furniture of a coin or a disc.
Okay?
If I want the moment to finish
here through the center,
I truly have to calculate it.
You divided into concentric rings.
The answer for each ring is simple.
You're do an integral.
You get Mr squared over two,
but suppose I say I want a moment
to finish through that point.
You know what I mean?
Stick the pin through that and rotate it.
If some wobbly motion it will perform
with that as the center more minute finish
up to that point.
If you just went back to basics,
it's very hard to calculate because you
can try you a little trick with concept
circles. That'll be nice. That'll be nice.
Then you'll run to the edge and after
that certain ones are not really full
circles and depending on how far you go,
you take different fractions of a circle
is not easy to do. That summation,
luckily leave the moment of
inertia was through the center.
The whole object is divided
into the concept of it rings
and you can do the some
easily, but here is where
this DRM comes into play.
You don't have to do any
more work through this point.
It is Amr square over to that,
the answer to the center plus and B
square where d is simply the distance from
the center of mass to
where you sent your access.
Okay.
All right,
so that's one demonstrational
parallel axes, theater
on the proof of the
parallel Lexis theater.
Now I'm going to show you a similar
result because that's going to be also
useful in the study of rigid bodies.
It has the very same flavors.
I wanted to do that side by side
and that's the following question.
Suppose you have a in two dimensions,
a whole bunch of masters and one with
the location are one m with location art
too and they're all moving around.
You know that given all the masses,
that is something in some way here.
That's the center of mass are
as the bodies move. This is not
a fixed situation. The whole,
it could be a bunch of planets
traveling as seen by another galaxy.
The whole solar system is drifting.
Then ask,
the whole thing is drifting.
That center of mass,
which is the weighted average of the
location to, we'll also drift with that.
Now I want to write a formula for
the Kennedy Energy of this complex,
which is one half some
over I am I the I squared?
No. I want to look at the velocity of
this object of every object to be I,
I want to see it as the velocity of the
center of mass listed velocity relative
to the center of mass, which I will
denote maybe with the symbol r [inaudible]
you see that every little speck is moving,
but let's ride in a frame moving with
the center of miles. Wherever it goes,
we go with that.
We latch onto it as seen by us.
The body will have a velocity,
the a relative,
but from the point of view of the ground,
we should add to that velocity.
The velocity of the center of mass to
get there the last year with respect to
the ground are some
fixed coordinate system.
So let's do that same trick.
The expansion one half am
I? No, I think you will.
Let me do this a little faster because
we've done the thing similarly to before.
Now I'm squatting velocities
in the of sweating positions.
So one term there'll be this capital v
itemized u is the velocity of the center
of mass. I just don't want to
show the subsequent every time,
but capital B's center of mass,
so when I squared this via square,
I would get a v squared term.
Then I'll get a bi relative.
Okay.
Squared term, and I'll get
across to him twice. V.
Dot.
Vi relative
some with all the products,
so let's expand the three terms.
The first term,
this is the last of central mass
has nothing to do with index ISO.
You can pull it out of the sun and what
will I get? I allowed up all the masters.
I'll get the total mass.
I get that a zone one half MV square
that does a Kennedy energy off
the center of mass. Other words,
the center of mass,
if it's treated as a point containing
the entire mass of the object moving at
the Velocity v, that's the kinetic
energy of the center of mass. Okay.
Then let me take this term.
This is some am I
the eye relative square.
What does that, you guys should think
about, what is this quantity stand for?
Can you tell me what it stands for?
Yeah.
The kinetic energy of the object's
relative to the central. Yeah.
It means if you're really traveling
with the center of mass and you made a
measurement on how fast
everybody is moving,
this is the energy you will
attribute to these particles.
It's not the kinetic energy as seen by
somebody on the ground who is static, but,
but somebody riding
with the center of mass.
So this is the Kennedy Energy.
A little bit of the center of mass.
We can give it some name. It's
whatever it is. But once again,
the costumes are going to vanish.
That's what I, to show you.
Let's look at a crossroad.
The two cancers, the half.
Then I get this capital.
We can be pulled out at the summation.
Am I
the I irrelative summed
over all the pockets.
M I v I relative is the
momentum of particle.
I I seen by this coal moving observer
who was moving with the center of mass.
So this term is really some over,
I have the individual moment of the party,
but you could go back to your notes.
You'll find the some of the moment of
all the particles is the momentum of the
center of mass,
but there's the moment I'm at the center
of mass as measured by a person called
moving with the center of mass. What
will that person get? Will you get zero?
That's the same trick as before.
For that reason,
the Spanish is so don't say it to me. How
can I say central mass momentum a zero.
We know the center of mass is moving but
that is from the vantage of this person
here. But if you go and ride
with the center of mass,
this is how you would compute the momentum
of the center of mass by looking at
the moment of the fragments as seen
by you, they better add up to zero.
What it means is if there are two
masters moving at different velocities,
the only two of them,
if you go to the center of mass
and right with the center of mass,
whatever momentum one guy has other
will have the opposite moment.
So the momentum office system will appear
to be zero as seen by the central mass.
Okay.
That for here is the result,
the Kennedy Energy of a collection of
masses is the kinetic energy that you can
associate with the center of mass
motion plus candidate energy relative to
center of mass, but I just
call it k, let's do better.
Understood is willing to at the
center of mass, this is just a,
it's true no matter what I'm talking
about. Collection of loosely moving,
loosely connected particles,
but now I play it to the case where
these particles form a rigid body.
Think about it now, so it's not a swarm
of bees that all connected better.
He did Raj, so they form a
rigid complex. In that case,
what motion is allowed if you
ride with the center of mass,
think about it. What
motion can you have? Yes,
it's the rotational, but you can be
more specific rotation about which point
and was that a good guesser
or was that a reason for that?
You're moving relative to the center
of this is probably you'll be waiting.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let me repeat what he said.
If you're writing with the rigid body and
you are sitting wherever the center of
mass city and the only emotion allowed
for you is the rotation around the center
of mass. Because if it does not,
I don't want the center of mass,
then the central mass, we'll be moving
relative to the axis of rotation,
but that's not allowed because according
to the center of mass is not moving.
Therefore,
any rotation that takes place must be
around an axis passing through the central
mass. In that case, we know
what the kinetic energy is.
There's one half MV squared plus one
half I central mass and I guess squared,
but Omegas, whatever the angular
velocities at that moment.
So this is the statement that the Kennedy
Energy is the summer of two times a
translation part and the rotational part
provided,
uh,
you separated as the kinetic energy of
translation off the center of mass and
rotation relate to percent of the mass.
It's a bit of useful result because so
far what we did is in the early part of
the course we took bodies.
We just translate that point.
Particles.
They have a massive velocity.
We got used to one half MV squared
as the answer. Last lecture.
We took a rigid body which
has a size and a ship.
We nailed one part of it so it could move,
so all it could do was rotate around the
point and we learned that the energy of
rotation, I've written somewhere
there, there's one half Iomega Square,
but in reality a body can translate and
rotate to anything you wanted. The air,
it'll spin or move and so rotate.
Then the kinetic energy
of that complicated motion
remarkably is the sum of two
terms. One, you ignore all the wobbling,
just zero in on the center of mass treated
like a point and associate and energy
with its motion. Then think of the
rotation around the center of mass,
which is all that is allowed to
that observer and add that energy
maybe for the mortar
mathematically minded people.
What is interesting is if you
take a plus B whole square,
there's an term terminal B squared
term and they told you long back not to
forget the two ab turn.
The Crosstrek practice across.
Jim always vanishes both in that
derivation. In this derivation,
it has to do with the fact that the point
that I'm talking about is not any old
point but the center of mass. So long
ago when you learn about center of mass,
you say, why did people think of this
notion? You can see it repeatedly.
It's a very powerful notion that if
you want to study at a dead body,
if you want to pick any one
point that you want to focus on,
it's gotta be central mass.
Yes, this, this problem.
Ignoring the effects of gravity.
No,
this is a kinematic,
that statement that doesn't require
that the particles are not subject to
gravitational force.
They can be subject to any force,
external forces and internal forces.
Whatever you,
all I've done is given instance,
take a snapshot,
dig the Kinetic Energy and
write it in a different way.
Take the candidate going to be seen by
a static observer and rewrite it as seen
by an observer moving
with the central mass.
So I'm going to play this to a simple
problem so you can get a feeling for this.
That's simple problem is going to be
a
disc.
You can think of the problem as
either a disk art as a cylinder.
A cylinder is just a disc
with a certain thickness,
so discuss like a coin and the is a stack
of coins or the moment of inertia for
the disc or the cylinder is the same.
Do you guys understand that?
If it took one coin it's
got Mr squared over two.
Let me put a second coin on top of it
and rotate them through the same axes
whether there's Mr squared over two for
this guy plus Mr squared or two for that
guy it then it's equal to the
total Mrr square four cylinder Rod.
At this moment of Venetia is just Mr
squared over two through the center of
mass.
Okay, yes, I remember that.
Now let's take this disk which is sitting
now and give it some energy of motion.
Think of it as a pilot in a, in a
car, one of the four tires spinning.
So there are different things you could
imagine. Lift the car off the ground,
you know, and the service station
and you let the tire spin.
That is rotational energy
for that.
The answer is one half Iomega Square.
That's what we've been doing all of last
time. But let's do something else. Uh,
let the tire hit the ground
and cod is going and get say 50 miles
an hour. Then you slammed the brakes.
We prevent the tire from Tony.
If you prevent the tire from turning,
you lock the brakes. The tire can
still move with a certain velocity.
V which is just the translational
motion of the center of mass.
So this is a card with the skidding.
This is a card which is either spinning
its wheels are lifted off the ground.
They had the two simple kinds of motion.
You can imagine.
One is simple translation. There is
notation to worry about the entities.
One half MV squared. Oh that a
simple rotation which we learned.
No translation. That candidate
energy of all the little guys,
all moving in the tangential direction
is one half I omegas where all right,
I'd real car. Both things are
happening in a real car. The tire is
rolling along the ground and also
rotating around the center and also
translating.
It's got both motions.
No,
the two motions,
namely that linear velocity of the
center and the angular velocity.
I don't under center in general don't
have to be connected in any way.
Suppose you to start your
car on a slippery road.
The tire spinning got cars not moving,
so that's Omega equal to not
zero but be equal to zero. Odd.
When the car is moving along,
you're slammed the brake,
then you kill the Omega but not the V.
I'm just trying to tell you in general
that are two philosophies that linear
motion to the center and the angular
motion around the center are independent
but one is this getting caught in.
One is a car that spinning his wheels,
but I want to talk about the car the way
we like it in a car that's moving the
way we like it.
There's a correlation between the angular
velocity and the linear velocity and
that is called rolling without slipping.
Yeah.
That's the term people use.
Admin is rolling without slipping.
I think you have an intuitive feeling.
If this guy is to roll with are slipping
on the ground, can you see that?
By the time it finishes one full
revolution vendors come over here,
the center would have moved the distance
equals the circumference of that tire,
so every part of the
tire patches of ground.
Then that comes down to that comes down
and when it goes all the way to this end,
you dishonest the finished
one full revolution.
For example, if every part of that
circle was colored with some chalk,
then when it finished the full revolution,
every part of the circle would have
passed the road and made an impression and
the length of that thing should be
the circumference of the circle.
That's when it rolls without slipping.
So what does it mean to roll without
slipping? What's the velocity?
Let's calculate the velocity
when you roll without slipping,
when you'd roll without slipping.
The velocity of the center of mass,
which is always the Nord by B is
equal to two Pi r you might it,
but the time to make one full revolution.
But what is two Pi over t oh,
let me write it another way.
Is Two pi times the frequency of
revolution because one over time is the
frequency
and two pie.
F is the angular frequency
in radiance per second.
So here is the connection between
linear velocity and angular velocity.
If you're rolling without slipping,
v Equals Omega are
all right. So in general
would be an Omega independent,
but rolling without slipping
refers to a particular situation.
No. In that case, that's
fine. The kinetic energy of
an automobile tire that's rolling
without slipping. So what are,
what do I want to get the candidate energy
is one half M v squared plus one half
I omega squared.
That's always true.
I is always I to the center of mass,
but now I'm going to use the fact that
it is one half m B squared plus one over
two m r squared over
two we'll make a square.
Not done anything different,
but now we must remember that Omega are,
here's the velocity of the car.
So if I do that,
I find going back to this corner here,
k equals one half MV squared.
That's one fort Mv Square.
So you can write it as one half
times the m over to the square.
So the kinetic energy of the rotating
tire is not just one half MV squared.
If it's rolling without slipping,
it's incumbent on the tire to have some
rotational energy that's correlated with
this translational energy.
So the total energy will be this.
But I'm going to write this in a different
way. Let me replace V by Omega are.
So I can write it as one half by
m m m over two times r square.
Make a square.
And that means it's equal to one half
m r squared plus one half amrs square.
I'm still Omega Square.
There's a lot of rewriting.
So if you don't follow all the details,
now you can go back and check
the inflammadry at steps.
But what do you notice about this formula?
I
want you to think about what the
formula such as to suggest anything.
The stuff in the brackets.
Yes, yes you, yeah.
What do you see in the brackets
that is [inaudible] we got
the more specific than just
saying hi. That's correct.
So this term is a moment
of finish up this,
pick the center of mass
and this looks like
walking up.
Yeah. Somebody in the last year. Yes.
One minute.
Uh, not hollow ring, but I'm
having something else in mind. Yes.
Right.
Let me repeat what he said.
If you ask me what's the moment of
inertia of the tire with respect to this
point,
what will you do?
You'll do the paddle Alexis
theater on the parallel axis data.
We'll give you mr squared
over two for the moment.
It finishes with the center
and an extra MD squared,
which now becomes m r squared.
So this is really
one half I watch that we call it
road or something. It's up to you.
You can call it whatever you like.
Here's the moment of inertia with respect
to this point of contact on the road.
Well, you have to think about the
result. It's a very interesting result.
It is telling you the entire energy off
this tire is as though it is rotating.
I don't disappoint with angular
velocity, Omega, forget translation.
It just a pure rotation around this point.
I vendor just rotating around the point,
it means that point cannot be moving
and I will now convince you that that is
actually true if you
look at your car tire.
Okay.
How fastest are the different
parts of the tire moving?
The car has a whole is moving at a speed B
on top of this, the tightest spinning. So
if you take a point here, would that be,
you got to add an extra
tangential velocity which is
v Plus Omega are that just
happens to be,
to me,
if he'd come to the bottom part of it as
seen by the car is moving backwards at
this velocity minus v. After that,
the speed of the car you get zero.
In other words,
the front at the top of the tire is
moving along with the car at the same
velocity of the center.
The bottom of the tightest
is moving opposite to the
car at the same velocity of
the center. So it's really the last
year seen by the ground as you.
This is a very surprising result.
A car going past you at 200 miles an hour.
That is that part of the car that a
zero velocity, the lift off the ground,
it's not obvious that zooming caught as
one part of it. That's not moving at all.
It's not the same part.
Otherwise a card really is not moving.
But at every instance,
the part of the tire that is
the ground has zero velocity.
I hope you understand why it's a
cancellation of the central portion of the
overall motion with the rotational motion.
You can see the rotational motion on
the top adds to the speed of the car
rotational motion in the bottom,
subtract from the speed of the car.
And if you write v Equals Omega are the
two precisely cancer here in double bay.
Yeah.
So if the bottom point is addressed,
then the only thing that car can
do is to rotate around that point.
And that's the reason why the energy comes
out to be purely rotational energy or
on the center.
So this is a simple problem
that illustrates all the
things you have learned
today, how to use the parallax theater
and how to do the energy calculation,
how to interpret the energy calculations.
But now this is useful for the following
example. Suppose I have a little slope.
I release an object from the top and I
asked you how fast is it moving when it
comes here.
If it's a point mass
and the heifers is age,
we know from very elementary ideas if it,
if it's a point mass.
So don't quote me on this.
If it's a point mass,
I would say MGH has
become one half MV way.
Kennedy potential has become kinetic.
But if it is a cylinder rolling without
slipping and it comes here in the center
of mass,
cannot move at this speed
because it's gotta be a lower speed.
So that the rotational energy
plus translation energy
without blame g h so this
must be equal to the
total Kennedy Kennedy.
And I've sold it for you guys to remember
that you have to write three over two
m this were to go back to
whatever was done here,
uh,
here.
So you can see that if you cancel the
mass, you're going to get v squared,
not equal.
The two g h as you normally would,
you're going to get
[inaudible] for 30 days,
so it'd be moving somewhat slower.
Then a
point mark party.
So if it runs without slipping,
then you will be traveling
slower at the foot of the rack.
So what did I do? I use the law of
conservation of energy. That's all I did.
But in finding the kinetic
energy at the bottom,
I was careful to not just
take one half MV squared,
which is the energy of a point particle,
but take the kinetic energy
of translation and rotation,
which I've done for you here.
That's the kinetic and the plan selection.
That's the kinetic energy of rotation.
By the way,
don't make the mistake of thinking it
is three 40 MV squared for everything.
It is three 40 Mba squared for a cylinder,
if which is this it or something.
You got to add a different thing,
but every time you will have to find a
moment of an issue you do rotation and
add to the energy of the rotation
at the energy of translation.
You follow that for each body it'll
have a different moment of furniture,
so you've got to use in the
place at one half MV squared.
Let me just tell you for a sphere,
if this was a sphere, not a disc,
they all look the same, but if it's
a sphere, this one half Mv Square,
I think it's two fifth Mr Square,
the different number, but then it's
all Mr squared times some number.
So you can take the artist squared
out of this and turn it into v Square.
So you will find instead of just the mass,
you'll get some multiple of the mass
entering here in the Kennedy Energy and to
the extent that's bigger than the mass,
the velocity will be that much slower.
So that are all cancer variants you can
have. Here's a variation of this theme.
You remember that when you
want to do the loop, the loop,
if you release a block
from here at the top,
I have shown you many times velocity
squared has to be bigger than or equal to
argue. That's the make sure it
doesn't just fall down to the track.
That's the critical time at with
the track is exerting zero force.
If you went faster than that, it'll push
you down and everything would be fine.
Do you went slower than that? You will
fall down. Okay, but now it's supposed to,
it's not a point mass,
but a object like it coin on a
disk rolling with our slipping.
It is still true. Be Square at least has
to be equal to RG, but to find the visa,
wait here you will use
the law of conservation of
energy. That's all just fine.
The potential energy here will be empty
times two are working channel energy.
Here is AMG at times are yes,
don't make the mistake of saying the
kinetic energy is one half MV squared and
put basically medical RG. That would be
wrong. This am here. Maybe become three,
four that nine seventh or
whatever it is for that body.
So it's the same idea but you can add
more and more ideas and put them together
and make a more interesting problem.
But if I were to summarize in one sentence
what I've told you all of this time,
you said when rigid bodies move,
they have a translational and
rotational energy in general,
they are independent numbers,
but when you have a rolling
without slipping the angular
velocity of the linear
velocity,
I've connected in this fashion so it's
not surprising that the total energy has
got a contribution from both
which you can read, right?
Eight and in terms of the angular
velocity are the linear velocity.
In other words,
if I don't how fast the wheel is spinning,
I can tell you how fast the car is moving.
If I tell you how fast the car is moving,
I inaugurated with the wheels are
spinning, provided is not skidding.
If it's getting,
these bets are off.
All right,
so now we continue with this saga of
rotations and let me remind you where we
stand.
When I did F equals,
I may after telling you a little bit
about how mass is measured and everybody
knew who acceleration measured,
what did we do?
The first took a bunch of problems where
some forces that are acting on a body,
maybe something is pulling,
something is pushing,
then learn how to find the acceleration.
Then uh,
I took other cases where there are many
bodies exerting a mutual force on each
other than if that had no external forces.
We saw the turtle momentum.
Other system is concerned.
They are going to do analogous things
with our new found equation at Tao week
was I alpha.
You want to get used to more?
That's all.
That's all I'm going to do from now on.
I already told you in the beginning,
uh,
that new thing you learned was topic
was I Alpha and we are going to use it.
So let's take various
situations where we can do this.
So let me take a simple example or
you can make up your own problem.
It doesn't matter, but get
practice. One possibility is uh,
it is a disk like a merry go round.
It's sitting still.
He's got a massive, got it radius
and I wound up play a torque.
So one way to play the Torque is
the way kids do. You know you,
you grabbed the sandy and you run
with it on the site and as you run it,
it picks up speed.
But what you're trying to do is I play a
tangential force as long as you can and
the force times the distance will turn
into a target and that will produce
angular acceleration.
Another way to do that if you're really
high tech is to buy yourself a rocket.
It's got some flames coming here.
Then if you just put one rocket,
the Dane did, what do you think the
danger is? Just put one of these rockets.
Okay.
You know what the problem may be?
Certainly exerted torque. Yes.
Yeah,
because look,
that will be translational motion left
to itself because that is a force and
ethical Timei is not gone away just
because we are in chapter 11 that's still
true.
So what will happen is this pivot point,
it's trying to hold the
merry go round in place.
You're putting a lot of force
on it because it'll try to move.
It has to counter the
force at every instance.
As long as the merry go
round doesn't fly off.
What'll happen is if the rockets
pushing and emitting gas at this way and
applying a force that way,
the pivotal level and opposite force
and as the rocket goes there ill play an
opposite force the other
direction but this bad,
this pivot is unwanted agony.
What you do is you get a second rocket.
Similar thrust,
put a diamond totally opposite and
habits flames going out like this.
So when you buy a rocket they will tell
you this rocket has the thrust of so
many uh newtons.
That's the force it will
exert by everything the gas.
So if it got a certain trust f here,
get another rocket at the same stress
deaf here did ADSL is are the torque
you're applying is an f
times r time sign of 90,
which is one and another f names are
from the other guy and the two parks.
That additive, that'd be the
torque. Then the rest is very easy.
What's the angle?
That acceleration of this guy?
It is to have our [inaudible]
by the moment of finish. Yeah.
Which in this case is Mr squared over two.
If it's a disc,
yeah.
What if they put some passengers on this?
Supposed to put one loan
passenger here, officer mass. Uh,
let me call it a little less
then what happens?
You liked the guests? Yep. Yeah.
Right,
right.
So what should add to the denominator?
Uh,
yes.
All right. That sounds to connect. Uh, so
my picked it is wrong. Saudi for this one.
This r should be capital r and
let's use for this mass here.
Small are small. Honors. Square
capitalized is the symbol.
I wanted to use Florida. Oh
my God, this is a nightmare.
I have to change it in so many places.
I guess once I started down this road,
I have to do that. Okay.
Look, it's very natural.
That big [inaudible] is the disc radius
and small artists. Some point in sight,
but I did, I was not planning to
put this guy in the platforms.
I just used the random symbol that
everybody understand. Now for the moment,
computation is the radius of the
disk for the moment of inertia up.
The little person we put on
this little r squared. Okay,
so that's simplest example
of using [inaudible].
Once the rockets start burning,
you got this alpha.
I can ask you things like how many
degrees has rotated after 19 seconds.
Then you should know what to do.
Data is stayed or not, plus Omega,
not t plus one half alpha, t square
data and art. You can choose to be zero.
Initial angle of velocity was zero,
just one half Alpha t squared,
but alpha is this.
You put the number of seconds they gave
you that will tell you how many ang
degrees it as rotated by
that time. If they say, how
many revolutions has it made,
then what will you do?
Yes. Any idea? Yup.
Divided by two Pi to Pi is
one full revolution. These
are things you must know.
Okay. Then if I say, what's the
angle of velocity after 36 seconds,
whether it's Alpha Times 36
these are simple problems,
so now I'm going to do a slightly
more complicated problems.
Yet it's the first complication you can
have that is the pulley and there is a
mass. I better get everything
right here. This is,
let's call it a little m.
Let's call that radius r and mass began
and I just let go of the mass and the
question is what's the acceleration of
this mass?
So this is a combination of
rotational problems and translation,
the masters translating the police,
rotating.
And the point is what's the
acceleration of this mass?
So we know from the old days that if you
want to find what's happening, the mass,
you should draw free body diagram with a
downward force mg and some pension t on
the road.
Okay.
Then you must also drive free
body diagram for the pulley.
When you look at the free
body diagram for the pulley,
I have a tension t acting down here.
How about run all the forces on this?
Yup.
Right? So this pivot point is
going to be playing some forces.
Basically what it has to do is to overcome
the weight of this mass and overcome
this tension t but I'm not
going to bother to write that.
I'll tell you why. So this
is an incomplete picture.
That is something else here.
But I won't pay any attention
to it because I'm going
to use torque called the I
Alpha and I'm going to take the torque
through the center and this is something
they'll come over and over again.
You could take a torque through a certain
point. The forces acting to that point,
they don't get the contribute because
in the formula for Torque fr sign,
Tara are managers and that
forces don't do anything.
That's where I don't pay any
attention to what the pivot is doing.
This t is trying to rotate it this way
and I know that p times r is the torque
that's going to be Amr square
or Mr Square over two times.
Alpha Alpha is the angular
acceleration of this guy.
For the mass it is AMG
minus t equals m a
so let's go and cancel
one part of our here
but we seem to have two unknowns.
This problem, the tension t,
sorry,
three unknowns,
the acceleration a and the tangential
angular acceleration Alpha of the pulley.
But here is where you do the trick you
that even with the two masses they are
not independent accelerations because if
this point has an angular acceleration
alpha,
you can see that point as a tangential
acceleration of our times alpha.
That has to be the acceleration of this
mass also because the rope is being
given out at a certain rate and that's
the same. So the mass can go one.
It's only if the pulley turns
by a corresponding amount
to release one more inch.
So the tangents of velocity of the point
here, this is the last year of the mass.
The acceleration of that contact
point is the acceleration of this.
Therefore we have to use the fact that
a equal to our alpha is really what I
call a tangential in the first lecture.
So if you do that,
you can see that this art,
Pam's Alpha is just a,
this combination becomes a,
now I'm ready to add these two equations,
minus d and plastic cancel giving me
mg equals n times m plus m over too,
so we can get the acceleration.
The acceleration is g and you
might add by m plus m over too.
So does it make sense when you
get a calculation like this,
you can test in many ways.
Firstly,
the pulley is massless capital
and vanishes. Forget it.
Downstairs. Cancer, little lamb, little
lamb, and you get eight with, gee,
that's the correct answer.
Just falling down freely.
No, I'm going to subject it
to another stringent test
was to ask you
some points.
It got a distance eights
through which it can fall.
How fast is that block moving
when it hits the ground?
Just before it hits the ground.
Watch the velocity.
So you have to think about what
ideas you will invoke to do that.
Yes. The acceleration
constant. First of all,
yes. Debbie, when the back said yes,
anybody know if which is constant
[inaudible] how many people think it's
constant? Okay. See,
I don't know what you guys are thinking.
So I am always worried
whether your silence means
no idea what I'm saying. God,
it's so obvious.
You don't want to tell me that's going
to happen in a class with a hundred
people. That is this video. Unfortunate.
You'll be locked nicer if five,
10 people than I can stop
and ask you to one, a few.
But I asked you if you don't fall as
something you got to tell me. Okay.
Otherwise I just don't know.
So if a is constant and they use a
lot of you seem to agree is constant,
then you go back to lecture number zero.
What did we find?
We Square is B Zero Square with the zero
plus to a times the distance traveled,
which in our case would be h.
So let's put that in too.
Eh is this number here and
plus m over two times eight.
So I'm going to write it in the very
suggestive language as to over m plus m
over two times.
Aim G H O.
Anyway,
that's the square of the velocity
when the blockage, the ground.
So what do you think I'm trying
to test? No, what's my goal?
Any idea where I'm going with this?
Yep.
Because it's moving slower.
When it hits the ground
and it has less energy,
that means that energy is
stored in rotation. Okay.
That is correct.
But if I want to test,
if I wanted to subject
his answer to a test,
what test do you think I can apply here?
This has to meet a certain requirement.
Yep.
I want to show that the energy is
conserved. That is no friction,
nothing in this problem.
So if you want to say energy is conserved,
we know what we want. We want, MGH
has to be the kinetic energy
of all these objects, right?
So go to my answer here.
The same g,
H let's send all the other stuff to
the left hand side. If I do that,
I get
em over to B squared plus one half
m over to B square equals MGH.
All I've done guys is to transfer
this fellow to the other side.
Well, MDH is wonderful. That's
my initial potential energy.
There is no kinetic energy.
Nobody was moving.
This is clearly the
kinetic energy of the mass.
And last thing is is is the
kinetic energy of the pulley.
I think by now you recognize this
is the kinetic energy of the pulley.
If you're not convinced,
I can be places v by Omega are and bring
the r squared in here and write this
last term as one half
r square omega squared,
which is the kinetic energy of the,
so you've got to understand the linear
velocity of the mass and the angular
velocity.
The pulley are connected and the
connection factor is always our artists,
the number that connects linear
to angular quantity. So indeed,
this answer satisfies the law
of conservation of energy.
That's a very good test.
Now you can have
variations of this problem.
I don't want to do too many variations.
In fact,
I'm just going to draw it in the corner
of the board and I don't feel like
pursuing it because there is a limit to
how many things can be done in the class.
So here is a pulley and here to say a mass
and you guys can work out the
acceleration of the mass downhill.
It's the same story that I did here.
Okay.
You got to draw the free
body diagram of the mass.
You're going to draw the free body
diagram of the pulley and the are going to
say the net force on this,
bringing it down with the network and
this is turning it and you'll realize that
the a of this and the Alpha
of this are not independent,
but that the a of the block is
related to the alpha of the pulley.
By this factor,
then you'll be home.
Things will just work out.
I will of course depend on this angle.
Tatoe
suppose you did the calculation and
you wanted to subject that to a test.
What can you do?
Yep.
[inaudible]
uh,
that is no friction.
So what you're saying is you can use
the law of conservation of energy.
For example,
if there's dropped a certain height,
eight from that height to the ground,
your answers should satisfy the condition
that MGH was equal to the Kennedy
energy of the mass and the police. At
the end of the day, you're answerable,
satisfying.
Other thing you can do is if this
angle theta goes to 90 degrees,
look what happens if data goes
to 90 forget about a block.
It was just falling freely and that's
the previous problem and you can check if
the answer do you get agrees
with the previous rep,
so I'm just teaching you that. It's good
to have constant checks on the problem.
One way to check the calculation
as to go back and do it again.
Most of the time if you
screwed up the first time,
it probably screw up the
second time because one of
the basic rules of nature is
that if you repeat a certain
experiment under the same conditions,
you'd get the same answer. That's why
when I proofread anything at right,
I don't find any mistakes,
but my readers are playfully pointing
out this and that type of cause.
We cannot detect those errors.
That's true even for a
scientific calculation because
for some reason you forgot
something the first time,
you will keep making the same mistake
that is known in the businesses chasing
after pie.
In all the calculations we do.
We look at the right answer and
we look at our answer and we take,
the ratio is always 3.14 so we
know somewhere we lost a pipe.
It's called chasing after pie and chasing
after factors of two is roughly how I
spend 80% of my time when
I'm debugging something.
So how do you beat those things
is by all these extreme limits.
That's another thing I want to tell you
with is all of us are partial to working
these things with symbols
and not with numbers.
I think this is a big issue
in introductory physics
that I said resistance to
working with symbols.
People want to know what's the mass m
and watch the odd number or let me put
that in. If you put numbers into early,
you cannot test your answer for anything.
In the end he has got a number.
You cannot take the limit
of one particular number,
but if you've got a function that
depends on all the parameters,
you can vary them and in some extreme
limit you will know what the answer is.
That's why you should be already even
in the exam. That's not a secret.
I will tell you right now,
most of the problems they give you,
we'll work with symbols.
Now,
I don't know why it's harder working
with symbols. For me, just the opposite.
Once they put numbers in,
I don't know what the number stands for.
That is separate call it am or I call it
art and ecology. I know what it stands,
so you guys have to get used to,
even in a homework problem where
numbers were given to you, you know,
block of mass, 46 kilograms
collides with some elephant first.
Call them all one, two, three. Give
the masses, solve the equation,
then put the numbers. That's
what I would recommend. Anyway,
I think you can see here the advantage
of working with symbols. Okay,
so what I've had done now, I took examples
of topic, but I Alpha in all problems.
I did something,
had a park and it was spinning.
The target that came from the rockets are,
it came from the pool of this mass
art from the pool of this mass.
Now I'm going to take a subset of
problems in nature where the Torque,
the total torque on a
collection of bodies is zero.
So I'm going to take a
system that in many tarkes,
but the external torque forces outside
the things forming my system is zero.
Then you remember when the
external forces vanished,
then the momentum of
the system was the same.
P One plus p two was B one prime
plus p to prime. So he had,
he will find l one plus l two l three any
number of them would it be so in other
words,
in the absence of external torics,
angular momentum of a system is concerned,
that means it has the same value.
Angular momentum is conserved
if power week's journal is zero.
That's like saying linear momentum is
conservative. The external forces zero.
So let's take some examples of this.
Here's one example that is a disk on a
spindle spinning around the discuss some
more money to finish your
eye. One spinning at some
angular velocity. Omega one
on top of this is the second disk,
I guess the one millimeter away.
Andrew said rest.
Yeah,
it's got some woman to
finish your eye too,
but it's got the same center as this guy.
And then this one follows on that
one and the question is what happens?
So I think we all know what happens.
We all know the true will now stick to
get them rotated as a single unit with a
common angular velocity.
So the law of conservation
of angular momentum will say,
I want Omega one for the first guy plus
zero for the second guy is now equal to
I want plus I two times my final omega.
So it's a trivial thing
to solve for Omega.
This should remind you of the following
problem in translation motion.
That is a body sitting at rest and one
on m two there's a body and one coming at
a speed v one the stick together and
travel as a unit. What happens then?
We say the initial momentum is the
momentum of m one plus m two traveling or
some final speed is identical to that
with the usual dictionary for translating
quantities here.
Okay,
now let's take a slightly more
interesting problem that made it go down.
You're spinning.
I'm seeing it from the top.
It's got some angular velocity. I
won. I mean I ain't got a momentum.
I want Omega one because of moment
definition, angular velocity.
This is the top view and I dropped
a piece of chewing gum on it.
What happened?
It's very simple.
The chewing gum and the thing
will start rotating together.
The new moment of finish or you should
use here would be this Mr squared.
I think people seem to know that when
you stick a point mass on a disk,
extra contribution, Mr
Square, you'll slow down.
Remember, these are problems in which
there are no external tarkes one disc.
This disc is speeding up that
disk. A slowing, I'm sorry,
this is speeding that up
and that is slowing this,
but together they can actually end
the tour after the whole point.
Yeah.
What if this party or chewing gum was
not just dropped but shot from the side
like this with some Speed v zero it's
got some mass m this guy is eight Esr big
game.
Not what happens.
This is something that may not be obvious.
You a party that's traveling and then
comes and lambs and sticks to it.
What's the difference now?
Yup.
This is going to have to apply
for with the motion of the body.
Very good.
So that's important.
Excellent.
So let me repeat what he said.
This moving chewing gum
has to be brought to rest.
Be brought [inaudible] by the disc.
Little push it backwards and the
chewing gum and push it forward.
So it'll apply a torque that
Mississippi Chante angular momentum.
But instead of going through
that route of finding the Torque,
if I only knew the angular
momentum of this party,
then I will add it to the
angular momentum of the disc.
Then I would say that's the total
angular momentum. That should not change.
So the question is,
what's the angular momentum of a mass
that's not really moving in a circle,
but that's moving in a straight line.
And the answer it is,
pretend that is part of a circle
right there. Moving a disability,
what will be its angular momentum?
In other words,
if you had the moving party
and you'd look to your left,
the disk is spinning and you're going
at a certain speed at that instant,
you are not distinguishable from another
body that's actually orbiting the
center.
But what would be the relation of your
velocity of your angular velocity? Well,
your tangents are velocity is v Zero
Angle of velocity will be be zero divided
by R
had that incident.
That would be your angular velocity
because somebody we're looking at you,
you will be there now.
You'll be there later.
Your data will change and the
angular velocity will be be zero.
Our net 40 your angular momentum
will be m r square times Omega,
but you can aid us m R
squared Times v Zero over our,
it becomes an B zero r
which I would like to write as p
times r but p is the usual moment.
So when a body comes with
a tangential momentum,
P and plants have cell phone, the disk,
it actually has an angular momentum.
P Times r.
This is not very surprising.
Just like art himself gives the force
our time speed gives the angular moment.
So the surprising thing for you guys's
things don't have to be going around the
circle to have an angular momentum.
They can be going in a
straight line at every instant.
I can find the angular momentum by
asking what is the moment of inertia,
namely Mr Square and what's
the angular velocity?
The angular velocity is easiest to find
when this guy is right next to the disk.
The new, you know from what we
did earlier, angular velocities,
linear velocity divided by R.
Okay.
The last problem I want to do,
which I'm not going to do quantitatively,
but qualitatively is a very,
very interesting problem.
Go to a single particle in translational
motion with momentum is empty and we
know if there are no forces,
the momentum cannot change.
So NBA is a constant.
Now that translates into visa
constant because is a constant,
there's nothing you can do and now comes
the interesting possibilities that are
available to you when you do rotations.
And that's the famous ice capade example.
Okay.
So let me do the ice capades thing.
So here his eyes here, the some,
uh,
the answer or,
okay.
All right. So this person is
spinning around with some,
I lost you omega with that hands out,
you emphasize the whole thing.
Let's imagine this ice dancer,
there's no mass except for
the two dumbbells on two
hands are the two masses and
a person is rotating with
some angular velocity. Omega.
That means a moment.
Angular momentum is I times Omega
and that cannot change.
But then suppose the ice dams are
designed to do the following, which is to
drop the arms right to the
side so that for all purposes,
the masters that are the center, now you
really reduce the moment of finisher.
So what'll happen, uh,
so I will signify that.
And globalize is bigger or
Harris kind of standing out.
So that's a rapidly spinning ballerina.
And that's because what is changing is I,
if bodies curtained their mass,
it'll be very interesting.
If a body can reduce the mass in half,
it get double the velocity.
But bodies have no way of
getting rid of their maths.
But bodies can change that anger.
I'm the moment of here just
by redistributing the mass
and that's why all these,
uh, ice dancers, you know, they,
they spin around and they bring their
hands together at the speed up and slow
down to speed up and slow down.
What is interesting is the following,
if you go back and find
the candidate energy,
you would find a kinetic
energy's not the same
because Canada energy is one half
Iomega squared. The beginning of it,
it is one half one omega, one square at
the end of the day is one half I too,
or may got to square, but
Omega to Canberra, tennis,
I won all but I to Omega one square.
Yeah.
And you can easily compare the two
numbers in the geometry I've given you to
show the final candidate
candidate is actually higher.
When you start spinning faster,
you in fact have a
bigger kinetic energy
because if you don't make a doubles,
because you want me to finish,
it went down by a factor of
half that keeps iomega constant.
What do you suppose to square the Omega?
So we ended up product Iomega Square.
When you reduce one by half and double
the other, you gain a factor of two.
So take the simple case where, uh, I to
is half of I won and you will see it.
Okay. So you can ask,
where does that energy come from?
How does this uh,
ice skater pickup speed pick up
angular momentum or Kennedy Energy?
Anglo momentum doesn't change
but rotational energy changes.
Yep. Sort of court type
show like angular energy.
Uh,
you can do this without invoking any
new concepts using this old concept.
You just go back and say,
look,
I had only one rule in this game with
the energy went up. Ben. What? Yes.
The system itself is performing work on
a different elements of the system. Uh,
so that work is increasing.
Yeah. But how about who is
doing work? The skater is
doing, uh, work by bringing
together the barbells.
Yeah.
And why is that take any work?
Because I gravity is pulling you down
yet moving perpendicular. The gravity.
So why are you,
you had an answer in the last row.
Yes.
No,
but see,
you're not doing work against gravity
because you're not changing the height of
those barbells. You're
just pulling it in. Yes.
In your, you have a different
than the potential energy.
You have less the energy
and you're holding it up.
Yeah. No, but oh, oh, I see. I'm sorry.
I know why you guys had giving
this answer. It's not your fault.
Take the case where you don't
change the height of the dumbbells.
Go from there to here. Not Changing the
heights of the MGH does not the answer.
Yes.
[inaudible]
against this [inaudible]
yes, energy. It comes from the muscle.
But the question is why do
you have to do any work?
And I think since I'm running out of time,
I will repeat that answer,
which I believe is close enough
to what I was looking for.
When the dumbbells or spinning,
they're going in a circle and we
know that they have an acceleration.
We squared over R and we know somebody's
got to provide NV squared over r and
the person that's providing that force.
But as long as it's providing
the force but not moving,
you can move tangentially. But in the
force and velocity of perpendicular,
so you're not doing any work,
but the minute you pull in,
you're applying a force
and the displacement,
which at both parallel than
f Times d is no longer zero.
You will find that for these
things that tend to fly off,
I see set and you're trying
to not only hold onto them,
but trying to bring them in during the
time. It'll be just like lifting weights.
If you want to lift weights and you go
to a planet where there's no gravity,
you can tell somebody to spend you.
Then when you pull this stuff in,
it'd be like lifting weights.
Okay?
That's what the person's doing and
that's where the energy is coming.